has the penguin always been the
proprietor of a nightclub in gotham and
what does the iceberg lounge mean for
the character and his criminal
operations keep watching to find out
oswald cobblepot known to many as the
penguin has proved to be quite the
monocle-wearing umbrella-wielding sworn
in the dark knights side since his debut
in december 1941's detective comics
number 58. the character has definitely
evolved over his 80-plus years of
existence going from bird-themed crook
to politician to businessman and back
again he's been a little silly like his
portrayal by burgess meredith in the
1966 batman tv show and monstrous like
when danny devito played him in batman
returns in 1992
you gotta admit i played this stinkin
city like a heart from hell
some of the more drastic character
alterations tend to disappear from
version diversion but every now and
again some new twist to the penguin will
stick around for instance something that
has relatively recently become a key
element of the penguin is his position
as the operator of the iceberg lounge
the cd nightclub has been around for
just under 30 years debuting on the
pages of detective comics number 683 in
march of 1995. in his early days of
terrorizing gotham city the penguin
stood as a figurehead of the criminal
underworld lacking superhuman abilities
or the more homicidal tendencies of his
super-villain peers kabupat was content
simply committing robberies and stabbing
his supposed allies in the back so he
eventually decided to open the iceberg
lounge as a means of proving he'd become
a legitimate businessman of course it
was a front all along batman of course
sees right through it and keeps tabs on
what's going on behind the scenes at the
lounge over time he has used it and its
patrons as a resource to study up on the
happenings of gotham's criminal
underworld other members of the bat
family have visited the lounge for
vastly different reasons on one occasion
in the batman r.i.p storyline both robin
and batgirl went there to forcefully
gather what intel they could from the
penguin on the missing batman's
whereabouts and former robin jason todd
took over the iceberg lounge for himself
in the red hood outlaw series ousting
penguin from power for a time and
holding him captive despite its
prevalence on the page a proper
live-action theatrical iceberg lounge
has only recently come to fruition
director christopher nolan's dark knight
trilogy and the dc extended universe
lacked both it and the penguin the
batman marks its first live-action
outing at the movies colin farrell's
scarred calculating take on oswald
cobblepot serves as its proprietor and
uses it as a cover for his criminal
activities prior to the batman the
iceberg lounge did appear in one
live-action production gotham the season
three finale teased it and it inevitably
became a focal point of season four the
gotham nightclub has appeared in lots of
animated projects however it's been
featured on the show's the new batman
adventures and justice league unlimited
as well as the animated movies batman
mystery of the batwoman and batman
assault on arkham sorry we're full up
tonight
it's perhaps been featured most
prominently in video games though the
batman arkham franchise endures as one
of the most widely acclaimed batman
adaptations tossing elements from a
variety of bat projects into a giant
grimy gothic melting pot multiple games
in the series also feature the iceberg
lounge in varying capacities allowing
players to explore it in all of its
glory as batman himself the iceberg
lounge is featured first in batman
arkham city within the cyrus pinckney
institute for natural history after
batman battles the penguin his numerous
cronies and his horrifying pets tiny the
shark and solomon grundy you're free to
look around solve riddles and collect
the building's hidden riddler trophies
in both arkham city and its sequel
batman arkham knight the iceberg lounge
also serves as a combat challenge map
but you couldn't possibly chill at the
iceberg lounge in real life right it's
an entirely fictional place well maybe
not there is an iceberg lounge fans can
visit in central london the venue
promises champagne cocktails exceptional
food live entertainment and decadence at
a vaguely batman inspired corner of the
city appropriately called park row
fans can experience their own little
slice of gotham at a handful of other
stops without fear of being mugged by
joe chill park row includes attractions
such as pennyworth's restaurant and bar
an art gallery called rogues gallery the
old gotham city bar and the dinner and a
show spot monarch theater all paying
subtle homage to the caped crusader and
his bevy of villains check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the batman are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]